so it's my great pleasure
to um introduce the first pi data
cambridge meetup
and the second pi data uk meetup
um we moved online
uh just recently due to covet 19. and
for this particular event we decided to
do something slightly different
um we teamed up with pi data chapters
from all over the uk um
so we from the cambridge chapter are
sharing this time but we have
contributors and helpers from all over
the uk
which is uh was really a great
initiative to have
so this gives a overview where
in the uk pi data is represented and if
you don't see a
city there just you know have a look at
the pi data webpage
and consider starting a meetup yourself
furthermore
there's also a slack you can see the url
there and i'm going to post it on the
slack
on the chat function of zoom as well so
if you want to
uh connect with other python enthusiasts
all over the uk
or or just have a uh have a general chat
about what's what's
going on in the data space in the uk
feel free to use the chat function
after the meetup a quick
overview of the agenda so i'm
going to say a few words here in the
introduction
then uh in a couple of minutes we're
going to start with talks
by ryan callingham and matt wright and
nicoletta
clinazi then around 8 o'clock we're
going to have a
short break just for everyone to be able
to stretch their legs
and then at quarter past eight we
continue with talks by nick and luciano
and we aim to end
at about nine o'clock um we have
abstracts for all of the talks
so um feel free to take a look i don't
have time to
talk to them right now but you can find
them on the uh
github url at the bottom of this page
and i posted the link also on
meetup.com
so i should maybe say a little bit about
um what we are doing here at pi data
cambridge
so we are part of the pi data outreach
program by num focus
and in cambridge we have a local chapter
which organizes
monthly meetups every wednesday of the
month every last wednesday
we started in in 2018 already so it's
been
it's been more than a year now year and
a half and
we have four volunteers who run this
meet up
so um it's federico one thought she
can't make it tonight
uh euris leandro and myself ola so yuris
and leonu are on the chat as well
feel free to you know chat to them and
induce yourself if you want to
so i mentioned already num focus a
couple of times
and so i want to explain a little bit
better what this is about and hand over
to jim
who is speaking to us from nam focus and
texas
thanks ellie i appreciate the invite to
talk here and uh
i'm jim weiss uh i'm the events manager
for num focus and
i'm always happy to talk about uh get
the chance to talk about pi data and um
focus
uh and people often understandably
wonder you know what is the relationship
between pi data and num focus
or even what the heck is num focus uh so
real quickly now focus it's we're a
non-profit organization
uh we are located in austin texas uh and
our
mission focuses around two main areas uh
one we
directly sponsor 35 open source projects
in the scientific computer programming
and that number is always growing and
they include projects like pandas and
jupiter and numpy and scipy and
matplotlib and
bokeh and if only we could go to the
next slide
we have all the projects listed here and
i invite you to take a look and
see which ones you recognize and maybe
there's
probably a few that you might use on a
day-to-day basis
so have a look there and then the second
part of our mission is to support the
community of users and developers of
these open source tools
and that's where pi data comes in pi
data is a program of num focus
uh we uh the mission is to provide a
form
for community of users and developers to
learn from one another
uh each each year we host conferences
all around the world
um london is one of our flagships
um but we you know have conferences
all across europe in the united states
in asia
uh south america uh last year pi data
cambridge had its first
uh conference and you know we'd love to
see the conference there we thought it
went really well we're
really looking forward to seeing what
additional opportunities
uh assuming we come out of a pandemic
and we can start hosting conferences
again
uh we'd love to see maybe what the pied
ages cambridge community
can do in terms of conferences but
obviously also all the meetups that
um all these chapters in the uk are
hosting um they're they're just
really important for the community and
that community is like of the users and
developers of those open source tools
um and so we currently have 173 meetups
across the globe uh in 61 different
countries
uh and one of the important things we
like to share is that any proceeds that
come from
all pi data events that's both
conferences and whatnot they
go to continuing to support our projects
so anytime you attend a conference or
make a donation that money will be used
for things like small development grants
financial services legal services
operational health
promotional support because we know
the open source tools we all use here
they take time
they take effort and dedication from all
the volunteers that contribute to them
and support to know focus provides us
ways to support those projects
enable them to focus on what they do
best which is
continuing to contribute and develop
those projects
so we always like to first say thank you
to everyone for organizing and
participating in these events
your contributions do go a long way in
supporting our mission
uh i'm bumped i won't be able to see you
this year at pi data london pi data
cambridge in person um
but please that if you ever want to
reach out to me or
not focus you can either email admin at
pidata.org
or email me directly at jim numfocus.org
if you want to get involved or have any
questions
um let's go next slide
so if you are interested involved there
are a few great ways to do it
participate in a local meetup so
everyone check we already we're doing
that here
so we appreciate that attend the pi data
conference
as i said any money any proceeds from
those conferences go to contributing to
support open source tools
and those conferences also need to
always need volunteers so contributing
reaching out there's usually a call for
volunteers
and that's you know what really makes
these conferences go
and then if you have a chance you know
consider donating
or working with your company we have
both sponsorship programs for
pi data so conferences themselves have
sponsors but as well as
num focus has a corporate sponsorship
program as well
so either can consider donating or
talking to your company about maybe get
involved
and uh contributing as well and
um all that information can be found uh
on
numfocus's website um or my data website
i know it can be a little confusing we
have two separate websites but it's all
one general organization so please uh
reach out
look for some more information if you're
interested or please uh email me
if you have any questions and that's
pretty much what i have
the next slide is a little map of where
all our meetups are right now
so it's it's growing every day which is
really cool so i appreciate
everyone coming out and uh joining us
so thanks ola
thanks a lot jim um i i noticed
there were two people uh raising their
hands using the zoom function
um yeah i am i'm i'm sorry
that you cannot actually speak but if
you have a question or if you want to
ask something just
post them in the q and a section ideally
and and we will try to respond to that
so i think i saw the names
qi and mauro please use the q a function
and we will respond
okay moving on um as we are
as i said part of the num focus outreach
program pi data
and as a consequence of that we are
bound by the
code of conduct of pi data um
i'm going to read it out quickly it
should be all just common sense
the it basically says be kind to others
do not insult or put down others
behave professionally and do remember
that any kind of harassment
uh sexist racist or clues exclusionary
jokes or language are not appropriate
for pi data
um if you think anything happened during
this
this meet up this virtual meetup that
was in breach of this conduct you can
contact all of the organizers
you can you can email us on on
meetup.com
that has our contact details we also
have like an external contact person
as required by the pi data code of
conduct that's leonie she's not part of
the organism team but she's
volunteering to take care of this
function so
her email address is at the bottom of
this slide
um now uh i want to give a quick shout
out to our sponsors first of all uh
there's
ibm ibm is a num focus sponsors in
sponsors
them directly and they also put us in
touch with one of the speakers for
tonight with luciano
so we have uh two speakers or two um
employees of ibm on the chat that's tim
and and luciano the speaker
so if any questions please you know feel
free to talk to them
um the pi data cambridge meetup is also
supported by
a couple of companies that are based in
cambridge
um so there is arm which
fetch ai and raspberry pi foundation
i should say um so these companies
support the meetup in various ways um
sponsors pizza
raspberry pie foundation provides us
with
venue and fetchy eye makes a
contribution to our travel
expenses so obviously all of these
things are currently
not really used because of uh the
coronavirus
lockdown but uh nevertheless we are
inducted two of these companies
and now last but not least of course num
focus
um just some information
uh about the sponsors um i'm going to
put a link
of these slides uh on or to these slides
on the meetup page so you can refer
to it afterwards in case you're
interested in any of the details
um um as i said is based in cambridge
but the global company
and in the chip design business in
especially with a focus on energy saving
chips
so if you have an apple mobile phone
it's very likely that
a chip based on a design by arm
is in that mobile phone and if you're
interested in their careers please check
them out
fetchy is a company based in cambridge
supports us with with travel grants so
if we get speakers from other countries
we
can reimburse their travel costs
um fetchy eyes in the business of
machine learning
and and these centralized uh
transactions and blockchain so they
uh recently launched a demo which shows
the journeys of training times
um all over the uk and uh
are working on an agent-based framework
that allows uh users to start autonomous
agents
and and fulfill certain tasks for these
users
so for instance performing bookings or
monitoring parking spaces so if that
sounds interesting and cool please
do check them out they have several
academic presentations online and they
have also vacancies
on their on their careers website uh the
link will be on meetup.com afterwards
as i mentioned already we have uh the
special honor to have ibm
as a sponsor in this meetup so i'm going
to hand over to
tim from ibm to give you a
quick update
please go ahead time
you're fine anton oh hey can you guys
can you guys hear me okay
yes awesome well uh so my name is tim
bonneman i'm part of the ibm data
science
community team we're super excited to be
here today and be part of this event
the ibm data science community is a an
online space
for data scientists for machine learning
engineers for
ai developers and others in this space
it's for intended for data scientists by
data scientists we have a lot of
resources lots of learning
um opportunities and uh yeah
are growing at a pretty fast pace we
just crossed ten thousand
uh in may and already twelve thousand so
uh pretty good momentum
um i focus on global meetup outreach
uh we try to connect with leading
meetups uh in
in key tech hubs around the world um
which have a
good focus on data science and ai and
see if we can support them through
speakers
occasional sponsorships and in the
before times uh venue space hopefully
as someone mentioned earlier we get back
to that at some point soon
um so if you're interested in in getting
a speaker just get in touch with me
um i look forward to the event uh
enjoy thank you
cool thank you very much tim
um before we start with the talks
uh just uh one more um request for for
speakers
um so we will try to keep this momentum
going and want to have
regular virtual meetups um
so if you're interested in speaking just
reach out to us we have a twitter
account we have an email
account and of course also always
interested in talking to sponsors
so if you're interested in sponsoring uh
pi data or the pi data cambridge meetup
please do get in touch as well
and without
further delay i would like to um hand
over to our first speaker
for the evening it's my pleasure to
introduce
ryan callahan from relative insight and
who's also organizing pi data lancaster
and he's going to speak to us about why
does my nlp model
suck in production which got 96.72
accuracy during validation
the stage is yours hello
um if you can't hear me then let me know
otherwise i'm just gonna assume that
everyone can hear me
um could you
enable screen sharing for me please
well while that's being sorted um hello
everybody uh
my name is ryan like ola said
and looks like screen sharing is
there okay and i'm going to assume that
everyone
can see my screen and you will tell me
if not
um all right so anyways hello um
like all i said i am the organizer of uh
the
one of the organizers of pi data
lancaster uh and for today i have used
um our template slide templates so i
just crossed out lancaster
i'm the lead data scientist and
computational linguist at relative
insight
uh relative insight is a language
analysis platform which lets
language data speak for itself using a
mixture of hand tailored nlp
and corpus linguistic techniques
uh along with a simple to use ui
we don't want to just because we can
show you all the data that we possibly
can we choose to
try to only show you what is uh
beneficial for you
your project and your business um but
uh yeah as you can probably hear i
don't sound like i am from the uk uh
it's because i'm a native californian uh
who moved to the tropical
northwest england which actually is
pretty nice today
and i'm an avid antique postcard
collector um just before we get started
though uh with with the actual talk i
just want to
uh emphasize one thing that i my
background is actually in linguistics
um i i was a linguist for many years um
taught uh i taught english as a second
language
but decided that i needed to look for
something else to do
because i wanted to make more money and
i got into computational linguistics
and got my master's in that and
nlp is just one of the things that
computational linguistics deals with it
does a lot
it deals with a lot of research as well
but
uh i guess the the practical side is
nlp so uh
the uh title of this talk is why does my
nlp model which got 96.72
accuracy during validation suck in
production
so uh this talk is is aimed
at people who might have some experience
with nlp or have heard
uh uh heard of nlp before and i found
some really good tutorials online
because they wanted to do something like
text classification
or uh keyword extraction
um sentiment analysis and they they
follow these tutorials
and can make a really nice model uh in
no time at all
but then when they actually go to use it
it sucks and
why they don't know why um and yeah
and over the next couple of minutes
we'll be hopefully
addressing some of those things so let's
start uh let's set the stage let's start
with creating a sentiment analysis model
so
first we have to go get data right we're
data scientists we have to have data
uh so um i go online and i find a nice
nicely curated sentiment analysis uh
data set one that is
quite uh quite famous online is the imdb
data set it is
a whole bunch of different uh reviews
from imdb
and uh the sentiment of those uh
statements whether
they are positive or negative one and
zero
respectively um and as you can see
that's uh that's what we have here
so then we'll do a little bit more uh
nlp type stuff we want to
actually make the data usable for a
model so we do some pre-processing we do
some tokenization which is splitting up
the uh
the words um or tokens if you're into
that sort of thing
uh into bite-size bits and then you do a
little bit more research and you find
out ooh
stop words stop words these are these
words that contain no meaning
um like the in and or i'm just going to
remove all those because that's that's
not content i don't need those and
you're left with a nice
tokenized sentence in the end without
stop words
as you can see i don't know if everyone
here can see my mouse but i'm going to
assume you can
as you can see it is nicely tokenized
and then we do a little bit more
research and we uh want some to actually
extract
features from that so we use tf idf uh
which
not going into what that is exactly but
you do some research you find out that
it's really efficient and it sort of
emphasizes
uh content words and that's good uh so
we're going to use that
then we throw together another throw
together a nice keras model
a little deep learning model because
when you say deep learning people throw
money at you
um and start training it and she's after
10 10 epochs here you can see that our
loss is getting low
and our accuracy is getting high what
more could you possibly want
um and then finally we have our model in
the end
everything's peachy and we tested on
some sentences now some context here
um like i said i'm from california uh
tacos are my favorite food
uh so i wanted to see some uh examples
with tacos
um now in england where i live tacos are
absolutely terrible which is a true
statement
sorry if that offends anybody um and it
is very negative which is reflected
in our uh model but then if i just miss
misspell one word it jumps to highly
positive that's kind of weird
and then tacos and prague are not so bad
i was able to find some really good
tacos in prague
now that statement is pretty positive
actually but
our model is saying it's kind of
negative uh and then like i'm a big fan
of tacos that's also saying it's kind of
neutral
kind of negative where it's clearly
positive right
so something went wrong here something
is wrong with our model
uh it got really good accuracy but what
happened here
so let's go through a couple things
first of all language is not skin deep
or surface deep um so text just from a
practical point of view is a bunch of
unicode characters usually are ascii if
you're old school
um strung together and then those
sort of characters can be strung into
words and then those words into
sentences
and what are sentences what is a word um
so let's just take a word like spring if
i were to ask you just without context
what does the word spring mean uh
many of you would give me different
answers some of you would be like oh
well i
guess it depends it could be uh water
it could be a season it could be a piece
of machinery it could be jumping it
could be a lot of things
and we don't get that just from the
surface form
of a word uh but then even if we have uh
context so we take the second example
there
the uk has the best weather in the world
i'm sure there's some crazy people who
may think that's true
but most people will probably agree that
that is
uh sarcasm or irony
um but just from the surface form of
that sentence
uh you you can't really get that with a
computer from that sentence alone you
need some sort of outside knowledge and
context so language is more than just
the the the characters put together
so also let's just take a bunch of words
so this in this case we have a bunch of
words
now if you see all these words together
does this have any meaning to you maybe
you can have an idea of which direction
this is going but it doesn't actually
mean anything that's because language is
all tiny why me it has
it's a it's a sequence um things that go
before
another thing affect other things and
this is connected to that but
if you just kind of reduce uh language
two set of words
and then put those in a bag and shake it
all up and that's where you get a
bag of words if you've heard of that
term um
you lose a lot you get some things but
you don't get a lot of things uh
so you actually need some structure for
language um
now uh there's actually some structure
to this little tree that i drew here uh
it's called it's called a syntax tree
it's one way to represent um the
structure of a sentence and from this
you can see that
all of those words that we saw here have
been organized into a nice
sentence and you can actually connect
okay so here we have
should um should not okay those things
should go together but what are those
talking about well it's pineapple and
pizza
should not pineapple pizza whereas you
have another should in the sentence but
there's no not
so pina colada pineapple okay so that's
that's
a very different sort of should because
it has uh
doesn't have not um all this to say that
uh that you use a lot by reducing
language to just a set of words so you
need to have
other things and you need to know how
language itself works how
the the bits and pieces fit together um
and you may have learned some of that in
uh
in your younger schooling days and then
promptly forgot it
but with nlp it's quite important
another thing that uh may have made our
model not
very good is uh the data
um our models will only be as good as
the data that we put
into them and not all data is created
equal so in the case of our model
if you remember it was imdb which is all
uh film reviews and movie reviews
um and
if i'm talking about tacos that's not
really in the sort of
realm of movie reviews is it uh
i would have ideally wanted uh more
more sentences talking about food or
maybe your whole data's not just about
tacos that would be great
um i don't know how useful it would be
but i guess for my model it would have
been useful
uh so you want to make sure that your
data is fit to purpose
uh if you're analyzing social media data
you don't really want a model that's
trained on medical data or vice versa
and general models can be quite good but
there's even problems with very general
models
a lot of the sort of word embeddings
that you see nowadays
um are trained on very general swaths of
uh
of language from the internet um
and that's great you can get there's a
lot of great uh examples of language on
the internet that's how we communicate
we're very candid and open when we
when we uh speak on the internet um
but there is a major danger and i have
experienced this
with uh many a model um
where uh so an actual concrete example
is i was using
uh word embeddings to get to extract
sort of meanings
of words uh and and and their relation
to other words
and what i was finding was that my data
and my model was
very very racist and sexist in a lot of
areas
uh a lot of words that had to do with
power and
and strength and leadership um
had a very male hinge they were they
were connected to
uh words about men like man
for example um and those were those
those vectors were kind of clustered
around each other whereas
a lot of the vectors about dealing with
family
and then a lot of uh sexual words were
clustered around women
um now usually you don't want that sort
of sexism and racism in
your data and if you're getting or in
your model
and if you're getting your data from
just the internet as a whole
and you've spent any amount of time on
the
internet you'll know that uh it's not
always the most benefic
benevolent place so um garbage in
garbage out your model is only as good
as
uh as the data you put into it now
uh some of you more savvy nlp
people um you may be wondering well what
about
bert if you're not familiar with bert
aside from being a
character from a children's tv show
bert is a model it is a language model
that
was very expensive to train a very big
model that
essentially creates uh the
word or word representations based on
context
that you can then use in various other
nlp models
and encoded in these vectors they found
has been
meaning sentiment um
grammar uh kind of all all packed into
these vectors and it is
very good but it is not perfect
um and can cause problems just remember
my previous example of racism and sexism
um so that's that's a problem um also
these models are not small um and
they're not
cheap so i mean it was some of the
bigger models
just to trade one model took something
like i think it was like 200
000 or more just to train the model and
actually have the architecture hosted
somewhere
takes a lot of power to make it fast and
usable for your system
so that's just because they are really
really good doesn't mean that it is
feasible and also language is always
changing
so these models do react well to
context but if people start using
language in a different way or create a
new word
or change the meaning of a word a word
like a heat is added to the language or
like ratchet changes meanings um
that won't necessarily be affected so
you'll constantly have to retrain and
retrain
retrain these not a big problem i guess
but if you have the money and resources
but for smaller companies it may be a
problem
and who knows in the future we may be uh
getting to where we're
being able to be completely unsupervised
in our models but
um that hasn't happened yet and it
doesn't seem like it will happen for
quite some time
so i think i am drawing to the end of my
time here
uh so to conclude um that wasn't
comprehensive
uh it was just a couple things based on
on the one example uh that i showed you
of what can go wrong
um in in in your nlp models
and what it kind of comes down to to me
is that
uh you have to have a little a little
bit more of a
meta understanding of language to
effectively diagnose problems uh
language is
is always changing it's not a static
thing uh
grammar is not even a monolithic thing
yes there are grammar
rules but um that's more of a
uh prescriptive man-made construction
the way language actually works is
however people use it
um and there's uh a lot of different
ways that people do that
um and there's no wrong way to use
language but
understanding how language is changing
where it's going
uh needs someone with that with that
knowledge um
and then also uh nlp has
has gotten quite good in the past couple
years
if you're dealing with english but if
you are uh
if you think any language other than
english
you will know that language technology
is not always comparable
as it is for uh for english
um and and different languages will
function very differently from each
other and there's some things about
other languages that are extremely
important
that are not important in english so the
research is just isn't there and
until then we will still need legwist to
do some of that work
and i think that is it from me um
and i will be monitoring the q a
system if you have any questions and i
believe these slides will be available
somewhere after this presentation so
thank you very much
and enjoy the rest of tonight
yes ryan thank you very much for
for the presentation um yes uh
we we will post the slides online
um so um we will we will put up on put
them on the meetup page
um i didn't
i didn't see any questions on the q a so
please uh ask
ryan afterwards or uh during the break
um maybe a quick question for me if you
had
if time and money wasn't an issue would
you choose
more data or a better model
um if if time and i
i think i would choose better data
because
a lot of these models anyone can get
their hands on nowadays but having
a really high quality data set is
something not everyone has because
they're extremely boring to create
and take a lot of time
fantastic thank you very much
and it's my great pleasure to introduce
the next speaker uh who is matt wright
uh i think matt has a uh
he deserves an honorary prize he's uh
dialing in
from new zealand i believe to a very
very uh difficult hour for him i think
it must be the early morning
so um thank you very much for that and
he's going to speak about
uh to us about building nlp products
well good afternoon evening morning for
me
everybody um yeah i'll shout if you
can't hear or or see
but i'll i'll assume you all can
yeah so apologies with my voices um not
quite right yet i'm literally the first
you know you're the first people that
i've spoken to all day so um
right i've only got 15 minutes so i'm
just gonna i'm actually going to kind of
whiz through this um
so please reach out afterwards or you
know stick your hand up and ask a
question as we go along
but the the summary of my talk is going
to be
the the sweet spot between where we do
uh machine learning
and and where product management like
helps build build great
products and so my background is i used
to work in investment banking
mostly in like data processing like
running lots of uh trading systems large
data processing there
um and then i ran my own startup and i'm
on the board of another startup and
my partner is a product manager so we've
always had this conversation about
where you know uh where there is where
the research stops and whether where the
product begins and i think there's a
really
sweet spot in the middle of that venn
diagram where you kind of see
magical outcomes and and actually i
i think it's it's also um not something
that either either group
do particularly well um so
it's something that i've been
concentrating on and i've run a
consulting company
where we concentrate on helping people
with this exact problem so
that's sort of whistles up to the
background
what we're going to do this today is i'm
going to
run you through a project that a couple
of projects that
i've worked on and it's all to do with
uh trademark law so i think i can
hopefully teach everybody to be a
trademark lawyer in like maybe less than
a minute here
and then we can talk about how we we
automated some of the stuff and what
product concerns we have
um and then i can hopefully share some
of the things that you could look out
for
so trademark law typically this is when
you have two trademarks and they
they either clash or they don't clash
it's not more complicated than that
um so you have so an example would be
you have an existing trademark nokia and
someone tries to register a
trademark called nokian and a lawyer
will say
are these things are orally visually or
conceptually similar and if they
are then they'll find that um there's a
there's a clash between them and the
rule in favor of whichever one has it
was sort of their first
the goods and services are important so
i mean if you're talking about nokia for
phones versus nokian
for shoes then that's not the same thing
so there's a there's a sort of
uh they actually have their own taxonomy
classification system for
the world of things so um that that is a
thing called the nice classification
system so there's there's some
element there that comes into the
rulings but there's tons and tons and
tons of fun little edge cases
so here are some other ones uh you know
and you can sort of just
look look down this list and you think
okay yeah all right okay i scout mrs
scout yeah that's probably the same red
dragon green dragon oh there's an
interesting one there
like what are the concepts reading green
do we compare those the same or not
um does things you know can x and chamex
they sound the same
so you can you can almost see just from
the first few examples of like okay well
look i'm a nlp person like i throw some
levenstein distance at this and i'll use
you know we're defect to do some
conceptual comparison and you know and
you're like okay i could write i can
write code for this
um however i would urge people not to do
that
because when we when we did this you
know
uh that particular first version of this
project you know we we sort of
this is exactly the point to put the
brakes on um and
to switch over into product management
land and to think about doing some form
of discovery
and you know discovery is a fancy word
you know you can call it user research
you can call it analysis whatever you
want
um the important thing is that you stop
before writing code and start talking to
people
and and the the thing there is so we
the way that the discovery that we used
on that particular project and i'm not
partic
not fussy on any of them um we used a
google design sprint
which is like a a week-long um effort
where you end with a prototype on a
friday um
and and largely it's to do with um
getting the right people in the room and
and talking and listening and trying to
figure out a single
um problem to focus on but what we found
and
for that process was the the product
that we were trying to build was
actually you know
it was it was to do with comparing
trademarks but actually
at least 50 of it was to do with
automating a workflow that they already
had existing and they used to produce
these like terrible reports
um and spend ages like one of the things
they did was like
just because it was a word document was
just like literally copying and pasting
when they had to order they
had to order a list and they had to move
things around and they spent half their
time like going oh actually
item number 76 should be in like place
number three
move that and then move another one and
move another one another and and you
know you're like
well i could um we could build an
interface to do that and they will like
literally save you half the time
and things like that are the difference
between you know
getting your uh product to work in your
product not to work and there's
sometimes
um very simple things you know like
getting forgetting the machine learning
and in fact our very first project i
think we did
uh like 80 lines of python you know like
it that could be considered anything
like and it wasn't really any machine
learning and it was hardly any nlp
and we actually used mainly libraries
that were already existing
and it was some some basic algorithms
and actually that nearly got them the
whole way
so i think the you know the the key
point there is
be careful about writing too much code
when you could solve the actual problem
so the second part of this project
was around um trying to automate um
decisions from the european court so if
these
type of trademark resolutions uh
disputes go to court
they they typically go to the european
intellectual property office and they
make some sort of ruling
and luckily for us they have a half
decent
online resource of all the previous
decisions that they've made
so our the second part of this goal was
okay can we look through all of the data
and can we then produce a predictive
model that will say given two new
trademarks
what is the likelihood of confusion
between them based on the court cases
that currently exist
so this is definitely more machine
learning
and the usual sort of start you know the
data is you know
i mean i think when i sat in the meeting
at the end of this project where we went
through the
uh results with the with the sponsors
and everybody that one of their main
takeaways was
while wasn't it quite a lot of effort to
clean all the data you know i mean we
all
know that i guess intrinsically but it
was kind of nice to have a client that
like really recognized that that was
not only an important part but like a
key part of
of getting the project to work so that's
that's another thing where it's not
necessarily product management but
you know getting the right level of
buy-in from people to
make sure that the data is clean and if
you can get them to do some annotation
this is the lawyer they're expensive
they look he looks expensive this is an
actual client um and
they did a lot of annotation because not
every single case was clear like
sometimes you compare one word
with another five words and they choose
arbitrarily which word they're going to
make the decision on there's many many
many many edge cases
that could throw the model off so
great that you can have somebody that
will do lots of labeling and share lots
of feedback
and and is engaged on making that making
the data better
so that's that's a big win um i don't
want to like we got really good results
so actually largely this is you know
good good for us hooray
um but also like good for the european
courts because they do seem to make
consistent sets of decisions based on
data so cool
um and all the numbers are down there i
don't want to go into like machine
learning numbers but um
like a good good set of numbers um
the tricky part of this project and
we've not got loads of time so i want to
concentrate on the second part a bit
more
was you can go to a lawyer and you can
say put these two words
into this these two text boxes and when
you push this button i will tell you
whether the european court says
they will clash or not and they
basically don't believe you
so the main domain you know like
i say if you divided this project up it
would be like maybe
one-third data cleaning one-third
building the
model and one-third maybe more actually
um
maybe 20 building the model um and the
rest of the time would be
building user interface and building um
some way of explaining the results so
one of the things we used here is uh
shapley values which
i i hope people have don't have a look
at because
they're actually a terrific way if
you've got a tree-based model
of explaining the results and and like
not
not so much um just which features were
important in general in building the
model
like on a per prediction basis so you
say given this prediction
which of the features were activated um
and so that way you can help
hopefully help explain um where your
where where your model's making
predictions and this is another thing
actually
when we're talking about product
management so our
model we ended up doing a bunch of
feature engineering
and i think that i got the best set of
numbers with like 30 features
um but i actually got really good
numbers with
14 features and i think i lost one or
two percent
in the in the in the discarding of 16
features and so that was actually seemed
like a really worthwhile trade-off
because when it came to doing this part
which was explaining things
i only had to explain you know 14 things
instead of 30 things
and actually that made a big difference
in terms of the user interface and the
understanding of the client
so the biggest number isn't necessarily
the most important thing
when you consider the overall project in
delivering systems to people
so do go and have a look at chaplain
valleys they're very very cool
and hopefully i'll get time to write a
medium article on one of the aspects of
this project where we used
uh generally the chaplain values and
then used the chapli valleys inside our
nearest neighbors model to generate
which we'll see an example of in a
second because i'm going to do a demo
but i was
i've not seen people do that before and
i've got
very good results so i i feel like i
want like
hey i want to share it but be i would
actually like somebody to
and if anybody wants to volunteer for
this would be great um to like sort of
peer review
like the idea this idea because
i i kind of like part of it is
uh you i just would like to talk that
over with somebody
but yeah if anybody wants to volunteer
that then um yeah let me know afterwards
right so another
quickly whizzing through all these
things now um one of the
important things here is once you've
built your model and you've decided to
do some explanations you've obviously
got to build some user interface
um and there are actually some there's a
great book um link is in the top i'll
put it in the
notes afterwards um around
using certain set of concepts to explain
your model
and some of these things this is where
you know there's a really good
explanation of shapley values there
there's also um yeah it's it's not long
it's quite to the point um and we use
some of the
ideas in here about providing counter
factual examples is one of the things
um turning things into text you know
removing
um numbers um and and you know
using colors where you could where you
used number
categorizing things into small medium
and high versus giving absolute numbers
all these types of things um so there's
some excellent
um you know and and the other thing i
suppose is
sort of uh iterating madly until you
until you get something that people are
happy with so
i'll just do a quick demo here let me
see if i can get this to work
uh i'll just put that in the middle
because it'll probably show a little
nicer
so we had nokia versus nokia in
that one to start with right
so it's not complicated right it's two
boxes and a button um
right i'll quickly go through what's
happening here um and then we'll do a
couple of examples and then i'll wrap up
so what we're doing here is we're taking
the
earlier trademark i've got them running
the wrong way but it doesn't really
matter um
and we're providing like an overall
headline prediction which is saying yeah
these things are likely to be confusing
right so you actually don't need to go
any further than
further than that if you don't want to
but we're also providing
a a probability so actually this is the
you know the prediction probability
um but we've turned that into like a
sliding scale so that people
because this is you know talking to
lawyers so they don't really want to see
numbers but
we're pretty confident about this one um
and then we used
um these cards which are
text descriptions of why this has
happened so
the you know the look you look at the
two marks they're visually similar
particularly towards the beginning
they're highly
they're one one mark is inside another
mic that's actually a really important
legal rule
they're around the same size they sort
of sound the same
um and yeah these two are sort of
related
so this is actually really challenging
because you
these are this is the output of the
shapley value um
and and quite often you find that this
is one of the reasons i cut down the
features to like the smallest number
possible
because the way that a lawyer will do
this analysis is a sort of first
principles approach where they will take
the legal rules and build up one
principle upon another
and what we've done is the sort of the
exact opposite really which is
just said oh we don't have any
principles we've got some features but
we'll just
we'll just do what the data says and
translating those two
things uh or back translating from what
our model says into what a lawyer might
use as a piece of analysis is actually
really tricky so
um you know we we've done some
information hiding here so that you
don't look at all the rest of them
um because these are the most important
ones and there's a sort of cut off and
threshold limit and
this it's not always the first six it's
the most important
um number uh so that that changes
depending on the prediction
and then the other thing we've done here
which is there's actually really
i'll show another example where the
where the cases are a bit more spread
out
is placed this is probably the most
important thing is
placing the prediction
inside the context of all of the other
cases so we went and built this
nearest neighbors model which shows for
this particular prediction
what are all the other cases that are
like this case and what
what do they say so there's lots of
other cases that are like this case
they're all
they're all found to be confusing so
nokia and nokia
are like all of these other cases and
you can sort of see why right
because they are basically you know very
much nearly the same word elise and lisa
right um that's great
if the cases are really close you want
to see the cases where this is
the opposite is true so if you have
cases where there is no
similarity but the words are really
close i'd like to investigate those
and this basically just gives a lawyer
like uh something to
anchor their um the prediction on and
actually something it's good to cope
with
and we've had a case we've had some
cases where they they use this
system to go to the european court and
say look um
here are the cases that you ruled on in
the past that are like this case
and we think you know blah and and
that's actually really powerful
um and the interesting thing there is
that the
the model t that we use to make the
prediction which is a random forest
model is actually not the same as the
model that we use to make to build a
similar
similar cases model so you don't
necessarily have to use the same
model for presentation as you do for um
prediction uh let me do one more
and then we'll i'll just you know finish
up
so this one is red dragon
green dragon and so a bunch of different
features will get
activated you'll see the
okay so right
this is a more interesting case where
you
you know actually this rule is triggered
which is that they're conceptually
very similar if you remove the suffix so
red and green are actually really
similar
but of course they don't start the same
they don't sound the same at the
beginning
um so there's some um
there's some indecision about how
confident we are
around that but if you look at the
similar cases and you place this little
green dot as our case
and you place it in the context of a
whole bunch of other cases then you can
find some really interesting ones like
there's a really good one down here
where it's like star wars versus space
wars
or you have oh yeah here we go um
yeah okay space wars versus versus star
wars so that's actually going to be a
really similar case that i would want to
go and have a look at and say well
i removed the last two words and these
two concepts are really similar and they
were found to be confusing
and if i can find a bunch of cases like
that um i can ignore the ones that don't
that aren't appropriate for me and i can
concentrate on the ones that i do think
are appropriate and that will really
help
and that is actually probably an
important point to jump off
back to the next slight set of slides
which is of course
you know we we were really good at
prediction but we we
were actually a tool and i think this is
always an important thing to remember
that is very much an assistive tool you
know like at the end of the day the
lawyer
picks and chooses from the results that
we give them
uh and and makes their own um
[Music]
uh builds their own set of evidence and
makes their own set of decisions
right so tips and tricks at the end
um don't do any nlp in your in your
first
effort try and do some discovery um
yeah really difficult these these ones
are trying to get your
you know designer um to learn about
machine learning and you're you're
machine learning engineer to learn about
design i spend a whole startup's worth
of people trying to teach that one
it's hard but it's worthwhile get your
client to focus on some labeling now
that's great um
yeah concentrate on on
i mean i think the the final point to to
um to go over here is that i think every
part of our project that project
could have been better you know like the
we ended in the whole thing
in 14 weeks so
so many like not shortcuts but just when
you you know when you're building a
product you need something that will
go to market and i'm not suggesting by
any means that people just
throw things out there because you'll
end up with all sorts of um model
problems
but there is a point at which you know
you have to stop and kind of
move on and also you can be very
creative about
using user interface to give your
give your meaning um and i think that's
probably it sorry i've gone a little bit
over but there we go
no problem thanks for the talk matt um
are there any questions from the
audience
nice just have a quick look at the chat
answered
uh okay yes okay that's
uh nothing yet for you
so just two questions that i have for
you number one
uh are you are you uh happy to share
your slides
oh yeah sure yeah i can share the slides
yeah and and does the does the lawyer
know
that he is in your slides yeah
yeah he knows the project is about him
uh yeah i think i can't remember because
this is
like the third time i've given this talk
so i i did
certainly ask permission um he's
actually also a judge so
you know watch out all right okay yeah
but better be careful
yeah okay fantastic um
let's move on to the next talk which
is uh by nicoletta glennatsi from the
university of
cardiff um i i'm really
extremely happy that we have speakers
from all over the uk represented so we
had
um ryan from lancaster uh we have
nicoletta from cardiff
and later on we have nick from edinburgh
so it's really like we cover
all corners um so nicoletta the stage is
yours
and you're going to speak about the
bibliometric study of a research field
yes thank you nice guy thank you very
much holly and thank you everyone for
coming
uh also you're pronouncing my last name
uh really well uh
which is good for a change um that was
actually causing me quite a lot of
anxieties
it was really good it was really good um
so thank you for that uh so hi everyone
my name is nicoletta like only said i'm
based in cardiff uh so i would like to
uh open this uh talking a little bit
about myself and my research interests
so uh i am a phd student at cardiff
university in the department of
mathematics
and i submitted my thesis uh two weeks
ago
i studied uh game theory and more
specifically i studied a game that is
called
the prisoner's dilemma it's it's quite a
quite popular game
the prisoner's dilemma models situations
of conflict between two individuals and
my entire psd has been about
understanding
the emergence of what behavior emerges
for these
situations of conflict and actually the
second
logo that you can see right here
what is showing is how behavior emerges
over time
and it's also the logo of an open source
package that is called
axrodz python library which is a project
to simulate uh interactions of the
prisoner's dilemma
and i am now a main contributor
to the project i'm also a fellow of this
software sustainability institute the
ssi is an institute based here in the uk
and the aim of the institute is to make
sure that researchers
such as myself when we write code to
conduct our research we make sure that
the code is available
is written following best practices and
it is reproducible
and unfortunately these practices are
not always standard
in academics in academia finally i am a
coach
an organizer of django girls workshops
i've been co-organizing the jungle girls
uk workshop for the past three years
so when i started my phd i came across
the illustrated guide to a phd written
by
mike uh you can find the guide at the
link
on the slide and just to summarize uh
what might very nicely said
uh in his guide was that if you assume
that the bounds of the human knowledge
uh within this um outer
white circle then the way us as
individuals
we learned during our early years were
in school and in high school is in a
circular way
and that is because we're being taught
in several topics and several subjects
however once we decided uh to do an
undergraduate uh our knowledge starts
deviating
uh towards the bound but only on a
specific direction uh so for example
this is me choosing to do
my undergraduate and this is me choosing
to do my master's degree
now what a phd is is about taking you
from wherever you
are to the bounds of the human knowledge
and if your pc is successful
what you managed to do is push that
bound a tiny bit
now in order to understand where the
bound is in order to push it
uh you need to understand what other
people research is before you have done
what methods they have used and what
matters they have not used
and in order to do that in academia we
use
something that we do a literature review
so in order to conduct a literature
review you need to read academic
articles that have been published by
other researchers
now academic articles are very
accessible through the web
and for example if i wanted to find an
article that has the world
the word game creating modeling in the
title i would open my browser
uh i'm on safari i would type game
theoretic
model and we'll press enter i will click
on the first link that i kinda comes out
and here's an example of uh what you
know clicking on the link
looks like so for example we are on the
website for the publisher signs direct
and we can see this up here
and there are several informations
associated with the article and not just
the article
itself so for example we can see the
name of the journal
we can see the the title we can see the
authors uh i'm one of them and you can
see the abstract
now the several publishers and within my
field those are prominent publishers
and an example is a list of examples is
nature plus
ieee springer and the preprint server
archive
now all of them have websites that you
can visit in order to access
their articles but they also provide
users an api so it's a fastest um
nicer way to collect a large number of
articles
now there are several ways to talk to
the apis by myself i built a library a
few years ago
which is called hackers uh arca is
written in python you can
install it and what you can do is that
you can communicate through access with
those apis
uh so just to show you an example uh
what would you have to do would be i
would have to import
uh arcas as you import any other library
here i'm creating an instance of the
class plus which means i will be
communicating with the api of plus
what i want to do is to look for an
article
that has in the title and in the
abstract the word game and this is
highlighted here
i want one article i want one record and
i want the article to be
at start one so when um the answer comes
back from the api
i want the article at position one
this method creates the url and the url
in essence is the query to the api so
this is what the message looks like
to the api plus and then with only a few
lines
of goods what we can do is
uh get uh the message back so actually
what you're seeing here
is uh just the informations of the met
the metadata of the article that have
been returned from the api
so for example id journal publication
date et cetera et cetera
um uh so now what happens with the
publishers and their
its api is that the url and
the the metadata that they return
they're in different formats
but you as a user once you use oculus
you don't really need to care about that
so for example if i wanted to ping the
api of nature i could use the exact same
code but i would just change
this line so instead of creating an
instance of class i would create an
instance of nature
so i used uh argus uh the first few
months of my phd
uh to collect uh update like to collect
metadata
on the prisoner's dilemma more
specifically i looked for articles that
some were in the title or
in the abstract the word prisoner's
dilemma existed
and i actually managed to retrieve 2500
metadata of articles uh what you're
seeing here is just the cumulative
sum of the time the first article was
collected in 1950s
and the latest one in 2018 but in total
i have 2500 articles
now that i have this mate i did this
data set i started wondering okay what
can i do with this what are the
questions
uh that i'm going to answer what can i
understand about my fields
using these data sets and i'm briefly
going to talk about two questions
uh that i have answered using the data
set so the first one was
why do people write about on the field
of the business dilemma what are the hot
topics
that my fellow researchers write about
and one of the topics that i
maybe should be looking at and in order
to do that i used a topic modeling
technique
uh that is called lantern digit
allocation
i'm going to be calling the method lda
from now on so i don't have to
mispronounce it again
uh so ava is a topic modeling technique
so in that does what the technique does
it takes a bunch of documents
in our case the documents are the
abstracts of the data sets so 2500
different
abstracts and we have to specify the
number of topics
in this example i say two and then what
lda does
is that it finds the words that are
associated with each topic
and their weights as you can see here so
nancy's topics are distributions over
words
so now some words can exist in more than
one topic in this example game exists
within topic one and topic two but has a
different weight
and there are some words that only exist
in one topic and on the other for
example population exists within topic
two but it does not within topic one
but all these are not minorly retrieved
though the
the the number of topics two has been uh
manually
um typed in uh the algorithm returns the
words and the weights
so like i said topics are distribution
of the words
and actually now documents abstracts are
distribution over topics
uh so for example if we had an abstract
we've had a document
um that he said the social network of
agents
we can find how much each topics
contributes to that
upstream uh so for example using the
weight from before and the words within
the abstract we can see that
the topic one uh contributes 0.30 to
this specific document
by topic to 0.20 0.2
so this is what we're doing we're taking
one document and we
we we're generating a vector for that
document
uh if we wanted to assign uh the
document a specific topic then we would
assign it to the topic that has the
highest contribution so for example this
abstract
will be assigned to topic one
so one of the questions again then was
uh is two the right topic is it's two
the right number of topics uh i was
actually just an example
and in order to find the right number of
topics we have to do a bit of
experimentation
and there are a lot of measures other
that you can use i
use the coherence score in my research i
run a series of experiments where the
number of topics change between two
and twenty and here i'm just illiterate
illustrating v2 between
two and eight and what we can see is
that the coherence course
says the six is the appropriate number
of topic
the cohere scores is um is a validation
measure how well does lda perform
and what is actually measuring is the
similarity of the top
words uh within a topic so a positive
number is good
uh because the words that are highly
similar are within one topic
and that is a good thing because it
means that the documents have been
the topics have been partitioned uh
correctly um so six uh was the
appropriate number of topics based on
the cohere score uh but actually i had
to do some manual investigation
um after that so what i did see was that
within two topics
uh when the number of topics was six was
there was a lot of overlapping
there was some overlapping uh within uh
the words
uh associated with the topics and by
looking at some
of the documents that have been assigned
to these two topics i could see that
the research that we're talking about
was quite similar
so there were some overlapping between
those two so i decided
after a minor investigation uh the
appropriate number of topics was five
instead of six so i carried out my
research using five
so i use the 2 500 different um
abstracts and i perform lda and here are
the results that came out of lda so
these are the top words associated with
the five identified topics
if you're a bit um familiar with the
person's dilemma research
some of these will you immediately go
yes i can see them being
in one topic so for example cooperation
network
population evolutionary is just
evolutionary game theory or networks
social behavior study experiments uh
it's just
a bunch of papers that use humans to
simulate the game
here we have game strategic player agent
which is more my type of research
which is using machines using coded
strategies uh to simulate
rounds of the game and then there were
two that was when
it was not exactly immediate uh what
type of research they were doing for
example individual group
good and high and again what it did was
i manually looked at the documents that
have been assigned to this topic
and more than one of course and then i
understood
what the topic was about so this is
about using the prisoner's dilemma to
formulate biological problems uh
promising biology
and lastly model theory system problem
uh was again using the prisoner's
dilemma as a model but of real life
problems now
well biological problems are real uh
real life problems uh but it did not
include biological problems uh it was
just other problems
like operational research and etc etc
so that was the first questions uh the
first question that i managed
to answer with the data set and the
second one i'm briefly gonna touch upon
is is the prisoner's dilemma a
collaborative field
so the second thing i wanted to look was
like okay people the rights on my field
how do they write to the right alone
do they write with many people uh or not
and in order to do that
i created a co-authorship network
so from the metadata the metadata that
i've collected uh the list of author is
included
so what i can actually do is create a
network where each node is an author
i'm actually a node myself on this
network uh
i should find me and point me out next
time and
if two nodes have a roran's line between
them it means that these
those two people have written together
and because now this is a network
there's a lot of analysis and a lot of
measures that we can throw at
and that we can understand about the
interaction of those nodes
um very briefly and the easiest method
that we can look at is the average
degree
so if you only write on the prisoner's
dilemma uh on average how many
collaborators do you have
and the answer is three so during the
lockdown if my mom is worried that
all i do is work i'll tell mom don't
worry on average
research says that i'll speak to at
least three people
um so both these questions with further
analysis
and with a bit further measures and a
better explanation i guess uh
how this led to uh to a manuscript is
currently available on archive
uh so if you're interested uh please
have a look uh my co-author is
dr lisa knight who's also my phd
supervisor
was my phd supervisor and
uh this is all for me today um this is
my twitter handle this is my supervisor
my author's twitter handle
uh this is my website where i'll be
posting
the slides and the jupiter notebook
because i didn't show any of the codes
to perform lta
uh i'll have a jupyter notebook there as
well but i will also
share it on the meetup as well so you
can find it
so if you want to take a print screen of
a slide i suggest this is
the one thank you thank you very much
for inviting me to speak today
thank you very much for the presentation
nicoletta
would you mind uh copying the link
to your home page on the the meetup
afterwards no um after all
because i haven't uploaded the slides uh
one type of the slides i will
paste the url link to the meter
okay fantastic thank you very much thank
you so now
uh we are going to have a quick break
uh let me sorry let me just check if
there were any questions
i i see one why are why
not do that right now so adam asks
thank you for the great presentation
oh sorry now now i had just disappeared
okay thank you for the great
presentation what are the limitations
for paper mate
meter data and collection from the
publishers api
fantastic um there is there is some
limitation as um
you can constantly ping some apis uh
there are some rate limits
uh but they have implemented uh well
back then when
when i first implemented the library and
the the pub
the publishers apis uh there is a rate
limit so
you the code itself would pose uh for
let's say for three seconds
if the api asks that it has to be um
pinged every three seconds
so that is one limitation the other
limitation is
that at least two apis that are
implemented
uh within ours need a key
you can sign up and get a key i did that
personally
but i don't know if that's an academics
thing i was a student i can't remember
that but you can definitely get a key
and then you can communicate uh with
these libraries
and artists knows that these publishers
need an api key so it will just ask you
to insert it
and so that is the second limitation and
what are the limitations are they and
i remember once um collecting enough
from my triple e that i had to stop for
a day
even though i had a rate limit uh so
maybe some
apis will you know stop you from
collecting uh over the course of a day
and you'll have to start again uh the
next day
uh but these are the limitations i can
come up with i can think of right now
fantastic thank you very much um i think
um we they had a couple of questions
uh that were asked during the chat i
think they were
mainly for ryan uh and i think
my uh fellow volunteer leondo has
collected them all
and at the same time we are almost all
the way through the break
what i would suggest is just um that
liandro if you don't mind i will
uh co coordinate let you coordinate the
question answer
session and afterwards we have a very
quick break and sort of
aim to reconvene at maybe 20 past eight
so and then sort of like six to eight
minutes
um two more very short things that i
wanted to announce
um before we uh move to the questions
um i forgot to say that in the beginning
so we are recording this meeting
i i know there were a couple of people
having audio problems very sorry about
that you'll find the recording
afterwards on the
pi data youtube channel and number two
um if you are interested in donating
directly to
num focus and pi data there is a link
which takes you straight to
the donation page so i'm going to post
this link on the chat right now during
the break
please consider donating and supporting
open source software development
thank you very much and uh over to you
liam
yep can you hear me
yep okay so uh
yes so there were two questions for
ryan uh one is uh
lots of focus on neural networks for nlp
what's your opinion on more traditional
approaches uh like tf-idf followed by
extreme boost cut boost or similar
there we go um yeah so
um yeah i just chose a neural net
example for that but
uh if the problem can be solved uh just
like um
uh just like that said uh if one if
you don't need nlp to solve the problem
that's that's kind of a first step
uh and then from there if you can use a
simpler model on a smaller model
uh then that's just as an example for a
standard forest
and in that case
ryan i'm sorry you're i'm so you're
difficult to understand
at least on on my side i think maybe
your microphone is moving
yeah maybe the microphone is a little
bit far away is this is it
yeah far better okay
i'm um still it's still uh
now that you've started it for the
liberty boards
no no
so if you i think if you yeah
it was better for a little bit
okay um let's give
ryan a few minutes to
set up again and get and have a
very short break three minutes break
just enough time to
get a t and stretch your legs
can you hear me now
sorry to repeat the question uh
so no i think i have a question i think
i think i think here at the question is
um
why why go big when you can start small
i think is the
the core of the question and like matt
said uh if you can first of all avoid
using nlp and uh find some some
uh just quick rules to solve your
problem that's that's not a bad way to
go
but as far as using uh more traditional
machine learning models um
that's always a good good place to start
if uh if if the
the task at hand uh would benefit from
that just as an example
i use my go-to model is random forest
when it comes to spam detection um
and i don't even use tf idf for that but
more hand selected features
uh to make it more generalized like
the length of words and how many uh
um uppercase versus lowercase there is
in punctuation
which i guess has you have to have a
meta understanding of the language
and you have to kind of look at the the
data set and task at hand to be able to
do that but
yeah if you can start small go small not
everything needs deep learning
okay thanks for that so the next
question is
uh well thanks for the great
presentation what are some of your top
debugging tips
for language models uh top debugging
tips
um i i think
it comes for me at least it comes down
to
recognizing patterns in the errors um
and that's not just
looking at the text itself but more
um what types of of words and categories
and sentences
are are you having problems with are you
having problems with
proper nouns are you having problems
with uh
with slaying or are you having problems
with um
for example um uh
words that have a lot of grammatical
words in it um
or if there's if you're let's say you're
reading a text and you notice there's a
lot of uh
sarcasm that it's having trouble with
and that that would be
a place to stop step back and be like
okay what
what can i do to this model or the
system to
put this information in there or how can
i adjust
to it so it's it's finding
finding um finding the the linguistic
patterns that there may or may not be
usually there is a linguistic answer i
found though okay
well uh thanks for that these are all
the questions i think that we had uh
pending um over to you ollie
if you want to restart maybe so we don't
get too much over time yes
yeah that sounds good so the next
speaker is
nick radcliffe from stochastic solutions
and the pi data chapter in edinburgh
um and nick is going to speak to us
about
gem test automatic test generation for
arbitrary programs with tdda
hi so is that working can people hear me
can people see this
yes i can hear you and see the slides
looks great excellent so yes
uh thank you ollie so i'm nick radcliffe
from as always says
uh the edinburgh pi data and also
stochastic solutions is my
i guess what we now call a data science
company uh and i'm going to talk to you
about everyone's favorite topic testing
and in particular the gen test
functionality that's kind of available
in the tda
open source library that we maintain
so some of you i hope will have heard of
the tdda library it's available on pipi
so you can pip install tdda
and it's also available in source form
from github which you'd need if you
wanted to try out the stuff
i'm showing this evening because it's on
a branch at the moment
tda stands for test-driven data analysis
and it's really a whole collection of uh
support for testing data processes or
perhaps more accurate
testing data and data processes
so up to this point we've really
described it as having
two and a half main components
the first one is for checking data
for verifying data if you like using
constraints
uh and so this functionality in there
both for generating constraints
and for verifying data against those
constraints
there's also uh support for extending
both
uh python's unit test and phi test
for testing data processing using
reference tests which are
kind of more at the system or
integration
testing end of things now particularly
the support is really there for
helping you test things where the output
may be large or complex
or you can't generate it by hand or it
might have stochastic elements that
change from time to time
and that sort of thing and there's the
sort of
half component is something called
rectify which is part of what we
developed in order to do the data
checking uh which
and what rexify does is it generates
regular expressions from example strings
and that turns out to be sufficiently
useful that
we kind of talk about it as its own
thing
so if you like um the tda library
currently is
two automated things the you can you can
look at the data
data checking stuff as a sort of box
that you feed data
into and it spits out a set of
constraints
and verifying code against those
constraints
for new data there's rex pi
which you uh kind of feed a set of
strings
and it spits out in the ideal case one
regular expression or if it's less
successful several regular expressions
that relatively tightly cover those
strings
but up to now the testing support has
been manual
and what i'm going to show you tonight
is some kind of
alpha beta type stuff for automating
that process
where the idea is that you feed in code
uh at least conceptually any code and it
spits out
hopefully useful comprehensible tests
i pause for applause at this point but
obviously that's difficult over
over this system so i'll just move on
so what we mean by reference testing is
um and it's very closely connected to
uh what the other side of the community
are community tends to call
reproducible research there's some of
that here too and the idea here really
is that if you have any kind of um
really any kind of program or
system that you've developed but
particularly we're thinking about
analytical processes of some kind
whether it's a machine learning model a
scoring system
a reporting system or whatever it's
quite a good idea to
record the inputs to capture your
process
in some executable form as a script or
whatever
uh and to capture the outputs from your
example inputs
which might be data sets or numbers or
graphs or models or decisions or
whatever
um and i guess those three things really
are are the
core of reproducible research and the
idea is then you
make those available to other people to
verify your
uh your research um tdda goes a bit
further than that
and suggests that it's a good idea to uh
capture a verb or develop a verification
process a diff process if you like
to check that the inputs actually really
do generate exactly the outputs you
expect
when you run your code either the
identical outputs
or if the outputs have variable
components
then equivalent but correct outputs
and there are various objections to this
which i'll move swiftly over
and the idea with tdda gentest is that
it helps you do that because
many people believe that testing is
really useful but don't actually really
enjoy
writing tests um so
the idea with gen test is that it's the
same process you still have to record
the inputs and capture the script
but gentest as your sort of friendly
testing robot will automatically capture
the outputs for you
and more critically uh write your test
and develop the verification procedure
for you so that you can
uh test that nothing has gone wrong with
your
uh code so
the model is you know you have something
you have your classification script or
whatever that's wrapped up in a shell
script
uh you feed in uh sure classify.shirt or
whatever to gentest
and it spits out um a test script with
one or more tests in it
and a set of reference outputs that it
uses for checking that things are
correct uh and i can nearly hear you all
saying
really is that possible um so obviously
what i'll do is a demo because that
always seems like a good idea when
you're
doing something live to a few hundred
people so
uh here we go so we have a very simple
script you'll notice it's not in python
it could be python
but gen test really copes with anything
obviously it's not gonna cope with
uh like mobile applications or whatever
but
any anything that you can execute from a
command line
uh this is a very simple one that just
kind of says hello and writes a lot of
stuff to a file
and stuff um i'm gonna run that
um and indeed it says hello
uk this is gen test running on
torso.local my machine
um actually i gave this talk before and
i've just been in munich where the
weather was better it's actually
beautiful and admirable tonight but
there you go
and then it's got a date which is the
kind of thing that changes
uh and it's also got um a file and that
file has a random number in it which
also therefore
is potentially a problem for a test
so if we wanted to test this you know
we'd have a little bit of work
to do let's see what gen test does so
the way i'm going to do it i have
gen uh i have the tga library installed
uh from source and i'm on the gen test
branch which is where you have to be at
the moment we will move it on to master
before too long
and i'm just going to say tdh gen test
which brings up the wizard you can you
cannot use the wizard if you prefer
and the first thing you have to do is
specify what code you want it to test
so we want it to test sure
example one dot sure but this could be
anything
then i'm really just going to say yes to
everything else so you have to give a
name for the test script but it suggests
one
it's suggesting that it will test any
files that get written during the
execution of this
code which seems sensible under the
current directory
um it's also going to look in your temp
directory which
defaults to the shell variable tempter
you can specify extra stuff extra places
it might not think to look but we're not
going to bother doing that
and it also asks well should i look at
standard output which seems like a good
idea should i check standard
error which seems like a good idea
should the exit code be zero yes it
definitely should
uh and how many times should i run the
script to see what happens well two is a
pretty small number but that's what
we'll go with
uh and having accepted all that we could
obviously change things along the way
um it gives us a little summary of what
it's done and what it's done
we didn't need file one that was just
the output from when i ran it by hand
what it's actually added is uh it's
generated this code
test shirt example one shirt dot i
and it's also created a directory called
ref and if we look in ref
uh it's generated okay so you can have
several things in one place but under
show example one show
it's created three files file one
stood up and stood out which are what it
expects to be in those things
so um let's see what happens if we run
the test
which we could do with um the pi test
obviously but i'm just going to use unit
test
um so if we run the test uh
five tests pass which i guess is good um
if we look at the code it's generated
um well so the first thing that might
might be interesting about that i mean i
guess it's not completely obvious what
it's done
but uh what it's done is it's run
your program uh it does that in the
class setup it's executing it here
and then it has five tests the first of
which in this case tests that no
exception was generated when you run the
code
the second of which tests that the exit
code is zero
the third of which tests that what it
printed to stood out
is what we expected uh and what's
interesting about this is it's not just
checking that the output was exactly
what we wanted it's using some of the
functionality in the gda library
to say well actually there's something
that i don't think necessarily always
ought to be the same
this is today's date and time uh and
there's also
the host name uh tulsa.local which seems
like the kind of thing that might be
over specific to the current environment
so i'm not going to check that the
output's exactly what i expected i'm
going to use this assert string correct
method
that says check the outputs what i
expect except
that if you see something that isn't
torso.local where i was expecting to see
that
i'll accept something else and the same
with the date
um it checks stood out there's nothing
on studer so it's just checking that's
empty
and it's also checking the file and in
that case uh it's used rex by to
generate a regular expression
so it said have a number but it hasn't
written the exact number into the test
script
it's written well it looks like it's a
five digit number
um so we're just going to say zero to
nine five times
um and that's what's going on now if i
keep running this test repeatedly
eventually we would probably get a
failure
uh but we probably don't have time for
that the reason we get a failure is
sometimes it won't be a five-digit
number it generates it'll be a
four-digit
or if we're really unlucky a three-digit
and in fact that's what's happened here
so we got quite lucky that happened
quickly we could obviously easily edit
the code if we wanted to but the other
nice thing to notice
is that it's not just told us that the
test failed
it's also told us what command we would
want to use
to see what the difference actually was
i'll just change that to opendiv
um and so we see that the difference is
indeed it generates a four-digit number
instead of a five-digit number so the
next thing we might
do is go in and change that regular
expression to be
four or five or indeed um one to five i
guess
or one to six or whatever to specify
what we want
so that's that's the essence of gen test
um i said i'd be quick so
i will go back if i can find my talk
which i can't because
it's covered up um so that's that's
the essence of uh what the gen test
functionality in tdda does
um it works by using a whole bunch of
heuristics by using the
regular expression generation to spot
variations in code when you
run it several times it uses knowledge
of the environment to say
i know where you're running this code so
if there are outputs that seem specific
to the path
uh to the directory you're running in
i'm i'm not going to
hardwire those same with things like
dates and times it know when it knows
when it's running
it knows who the user is and stuff like
that so using all this
it makes what i'm boldly going to call
intelligent decisions about how and what
to test
um though when i say intelligent i mean
kind of somewhere probably north of the
intelligence of the u.s president but
maybe
south of the intelligence of the new
zealand prime minister
um that's me uh if you are
interested that's my email i guess you
can't see it but uh the sites are
available
here on tidier info which is a blog
about this stuff um so you can find that
code's available on github as i say
check out gen test branch
check out as in get check out the gen
test branch if you want to try this
stuff
there's a slack channel you're welcome
to join if you're interested in it's
very quiet and low volume
um and you can find me on
twitter at various different places um i
think that's me
fantastic thank you very much nick are
there any
questions in the audience
okay when do you think a gen test is
going to be
ready for production you said uh
shortly after the robots take over the
world only um
i don't know uh to be honest uh i gave
this talk about a year ago and it hasn't
moved on a whole lot but that's
just because i haven't actually given
any time to it um i think actually
there's no reason why it shouldn't move
the only reason it hasn't moved on to
master
is it comes off a branch that isn't
ready to go on to master and what i
really need to do is separate the two
things out and cherry pick the right
stuff and get it
back onto master um i don't think it's
fully ready for prime time but it
certainly
is useful enough that i've actually used
it to generate useful tests for various
command line things that
i've generated um it needs a lot more
work to be
um say as intelligent as the new zealand
prime minister
okay thank you very much
so if there are no more questions for
nick
then please use the user chat if if you
have any questions that you remember
later on
and if there are no more questions right
now i'm going to move on to the next
talk
so for the final talk it's my great
pleasure
to introduce luciano resender from
ibm from the ibm open source data
science and
technology center and
luciano is going to introduce us to
elijah
which is an extension of jupiter lab for
ai
welcome luciano hey thanks and well
thanks everybody for having me let me
start my sharing my screen here just a
second
okay i'm assuming you guys can see
my screen can hear me okay if not please
let me know
so today we're gonna be talking about
lyra i'm gonna introduce you lyra
and i'm gonna use a uh
scenario that couple of my friends are
working around uh kovid analytics to
illustrate
some of the challenges on building some
of like a data science projects
and how alera can help with that uh
just a little bit about me uh let's
mention my name is luciano hezenji i'm
originally from brazil
but actually um living for about 20
years in the u.s
i'm currently at california i work for
ibm in a group called
code8 which stands for center for open
source data and ai technologies
and if you need to reach me and here is
information that you can use
um i'm usually available and and very
quick on responding except for my time
zone differences but feel free to reach
me
i know we are running out of time so i'm
going to skip a couple of this slides
but i
only think that i want to mention here
is that a lot of like times we talk
about ibm and we
look into that as like a lot of like
proprietary software coming out
uh we do a lot of with open source
pretty much
we use open source in all of the
projects but we also contribute
uh to multiple projects
the group that i work on uh is called uh
code we started a few years ago
as a spark technology center where we
were working on
analytics projects related to spark and
in the spark ecosystem
uh we started seeing that we were moving
more towards ai
different projects and bigger scopes so
that's why
the rename to code to basically go
around what we were
represent better what we were doing
and uh let's go more to the focus of
these talk and talk
and what we're going to talk today so
i'm going to introduce a little bit of
like the scenario that we're going to
use
then talk about the lyra and walk
through the scenario around
exposing some of the functionality that
is available in the lyra
uh so we are currently living in
unprecedented times
in uh being kind of like a this
pandemic brought a lot of like
uncertainty uh
and many things were new and there were
lots of like
questions that were being raised
information that we wanted to kind of
like
start looking to to find answers to
those questions
and of course i mean being sort of like
a
tag tech guys uh first thing we start
doing we start looking for data we start
looking for
uh how we can use the data that is
available to start getting some answers
and that's exactly what couple of uh
friends that i have did
uh yes we as an ibm we did a lot of
other efforts with the pandemic we
provide worldwide analytics
uh data sets we introduced a
covi to our kind of like a call for code
challenge
but our colleagues start doing some uh
analytics themselves uh fred reyes and
they both work on code and they start
looking to
kind of like original data sets to try
to answer some of the questions that
they have
particularly around where they were
living after a little while they kind of
like combined the efforts that they were
doing
and increase the scope to kind of like
try to get insights both
from a u.s type of kind of like scope
but also romeo uh lives in in europe so
he he was also interested in
europe and that's what they started
using
everything that they are doing is
available uh
is available in a public github so i'll
share links at the end so it's all
available in
all kind of like open source as well
uh when they started looking to these
they started seeing a
few challenges uh
so like for example uh how to break
apart the tasks that are expensive to
run so like data preparation take a
while
but once you have that data it's kind of
like okay to to start
looking into some of the analytics these
data are being frequently updated
uh and then once you have information
how do you start
uh submitting and making those kind of
like sharing and collaborating with
others
uh so we started looking into this uh
and we we saw that it fitted very well
with the concept of
pipelines and elena was introducing the
visual editor to build
a notebook based ai pipelines it
simplifies the conversion of multiple
notebooks into batch jobs and workflows
with the pipeline editor that alera was
providing
we could start adding multiple notebooks
uh define dependencies between them
which will influence kind of like the
execution order
as well as populate additional
properties required to run those
notebooks
you could define for example a docker
image
uh which basically defines the runtime
which is going to be used for running
those
uh you can define dependencies that you
may need or you also can define kind of
like
what are the outputs of this kind of
like tasks uh so
we talked a lot and i started helping
them
uh basically managing
or or creating the pipelines via elira
to
put together all of this nice work that
they they were doing
in in this project
so we can see here so like phases that
we identified so like a data preparation
and then kind of like a
model uh training model validation model
deployment model uh
testing which is kind of like a high
level phases of like an ai pipeline
translating to how this then becomes
intuira
you can see that we started filling the
nodes uh
defining the dependencies and then also
defining the properties that
each of those needs the configuration
uh but kind of like what is
a lyra
larry is a set of like ai-centric
extensions for jupiter lab
uh we originally announced the lyra on
april 29th so it's
sort of like a recent project but we
have been working on that
for uh over six months uh and we built
on top of
jupiter lab which is also uh available
for a while so
even though it's announced recently uh
we have a few good
set of like functionalities
functionalities available and to a
certain extent
uh it's not a prototype it's really more
like a
something that you can start playing
with a lot of people
ask me about the name of the project
what does that mean
so we tried to do a word play with
uh kind of like one of the moons of
jupiter
uh we look at into uh uh all of those
and then jupiter has a quite
a lot uh and the only one that really
didn't have like
uh uh anything protecting or trademarks
or anything was
uh elira in in
and we basically introduced the y like
in jupiter that introduces the y there
so just for those that uh have questions
about the name
um so we are at a data
so i'm assuming everybody here have
heard about jupiter
notebooks and know about jr notebooks
but for those that are not familiar with
notebooks it enables
data scientists machine learning
engineers and ai developers
to combine code and documentation
enabling interactive
code executions and the ability to
combine the results into compelling
visualizations
all within the unified environment and
entirely accessible by non-technical
persons of a web browser
if you are familiar with notebooks there
is the classic notebook that
has been there for a while there is also
jupiter lab which is kind of like the
new front end for doctor notebooks
uh it looks much more like an ide
provides the ability to work on multiple
notebooks
in or different documents at the same
time
uh jupiter lab is also very extensible
and the functionality can be
new functionality can be easily added to
the platform
and that's why we started using jupyter
lab and we started building layer on top
of jupiter
uh for those uh this is just like
jupiter lab you can see
this is the ui for dr lab uh you have
different tabs like you can see file
explorer
uh you have widgets
console terminal uh tablet workspaces
all those now become tabs and not like
single pages as in the previous notebook
you have text editors and and much more
elibra then starts extending jupiter lab
4ai
aim to help data scientists machine
learning engineers
and ai developers through the model
development life cycle complexities
some of the capabilities that we added
to elira so
uh we talked about the pipelines uh you
can also submit notebooks as a jobs and
we are going to go into the details or
look into how that works uh on the live
demo after a couple of slides
there is also hybrid runtime support
that enables you to run
notebooks locally or remotely seamlessly
that allows you to leverage cloud
resources or share gpus from a cluster
etc very easily
uh python script execution so now you
can not only edit your python scripts
but execute from
from within the jupiter lab and also
leverage the hybrid runtime support and
run not only locally but using cloud
resources
and of course you want to be able to to
track versioning
and share your
[Music]
work so we have integration with git
where it enables you to
very easily track versions there
so enough of like a sort of like a
theory or or let's really look into like
how all of these
work together let me start um
just
let me go here
okay so uh alera is available and if you
can see here
it's available on github.com
we have a few uh
repositories there uh we have the lyra
which is our main code repository canvas
allows you to draw the
the pipeline flow kfp notebook for
integrating with keep flow pipelines
and then some examples uh in community
uh things here uh if we go to
elira which is the main repository uh
you will start uh
having the readme shows you kind of like
the capabilities
uh you can see that uh there are a few
new capabilities that we have
added after we uh kind of like became
open source
uh so these are coming into play and
then it's kind of like we're getting
very
good feedback if you want to start
playing with this you can
use pip install uh you can
use a docker image there is the binder
uh which we'll just build in
our environment for you right away and
uh
conde stall is coming when we do our
next release all the recipe and
everything is done
uh our uh documentation is available on
the read the docs
you can go there where you can see uh
all of the
uh kind of like overview and get it
started but you also have recipes if you
want to
uh integrate that let's say if you
already have a jupiter hub
environment or if you're doing for
example just local development you want
to have a ksp to test your pipelines
the code notebooks is available on the
code organization
in the kovi notebook repository and
there is a
very detailed instructions on how to set
up your dev environment
but mainly what you need to do is have
conda set up
and you can run environment.sh that will
do everything for you
once you have the setup done and you
start um
you start jupyter lab you will see the
cove notebook
directory you will have uh
sort of like everything that you need to
run uh the kovid experiment here
but uh the two directors that you need
to know is the notebooks and the
pipelines
uh notebooks has a list of like all the
notebooks that are used in these
pipelines and we have
then uh the pipelines directory that has
uh
the eu uh data pipeline and the us data
pipeline and we're gonna focus on a
little bit more complex here which is
the u.s one
so uh first thing first we need to get
a good set of data uh kind of like
prepared for us to do any kind of like
analytics
we uh let me just look at the times okay
uh we go to this etl uh
us data uh in this case we are using
uh two uh main kind of like a
data sets here the primary one i think
everybody knows the john hopkins
um data set that's the main one that we
use but we found
a few inconsistencies there uh so we
decided to also
uh add a secondary one which is kind of
like the new york times
by combining the two we sort of like try
to minimize the gaps or make sure we
have even uh better date data there
and this notebook then goes about kind
of like a pre-processing the data
and outputting at the end uh some csvs
that are required
or that are used later on for other
projects
if we go back here then we can take a
look at kind of like
how we put this together you can go into
the properties and see
okay we are running this on a an account
a python 3 environment
so particularly when we are using this
we identified
the requirement to bring your own
environment so we enable you to
configure your own kind of like a docker
images to use
where you can play with any dependencies
or anything special that you might need
there
and in this case we don't have many
dependencies we are reading the uh
data sets directly from from the source
but
we then generate the output file so we
start making this uh
configured here what it's going to make
then what the larry is going to make is
once you run this notebook will make
those uh csv and json
basically the output files are available
for the next
um next steps of the pipeline
we also i start looking into uh
census data and incorporating census
data
and when you have the pandemic kind of
like data series
and you start merging with uh
information that comes from the
sensors you now have population of the
county uh
income distribution demographics uh and
how dense
dense the population of that county is
that significantly
affects how you can interpret start
interpreting the facts that you have uh
on on the data that you are seeing there
and that that
that gave fran and
romeo much more insights and much better
interpretation of those data
uh and uh after that then you start
seeing some of the analytics here
maybe let me show oh one thing i want to
mention
um clean data so one of the things that
they identified also was that
on one data set they were seeing things
like
uh here where data were jumping up
to a certain number let's say of deaths
but then coming back to zero and they
started seeing
inconsistencies on different places by
starting to merge in the the uh the
uh hoping kings data set with the new
york times they were able to kind of
like
find some solutions and work around for
this type of gaps there
and then on the analytics side you can
see
for example then they started playing
with some of the analytics in this case
they
they wanted to see how things were
showing up
initially it was very hard to understand
they started shifting
kind of like the time series uh zero day
to
coincide with the uh new york manhattan
um day zero and that started them giving
them a better kind of visualization of
the data
and once they have all the pieces
together all kind of like things
data were coming up and being updated
very frequently
how do you go and get these to be
running um
into kind of like a uh the right
the right sequence very frequently and
things like that
so the pipeline once you submit the
pipeline you can put a name here
let's say uh pi data
demo and you can select where you want
to run that
and and these are these the current
runtime that we are supporting is the
cube flow pipelines
we have an alpha version for uh
supporting uh
apache airflow as well but once you
click
okay here what happens is we will
package the pipeline
uh based on uh the preferences that you
have uh
put into each of the nodes we identify
uh dependencies and other things that
needs to be
sort of like a package together to run
and we delegate
uh these to get run in the cubeflow
pipelines
uh packaging and all of that might take
a little while so i'm just gonna cancel
i have already submitted one
and we're gonna go directly to that uh
so the submitted pipeline when it goes
to uh
kfp will basically have a similar
representation and all kind of like the
dependencies together
here and we we actually interested on
the execution of that so add x
experiments uh you have a run
created for that pipeline and what you
start seeing is all the nodes you
it takes about 20 to 30 minutes to run
end-to-end
uh but then you can see for example log
information and other
things if you are trying to maybe
something broken and you want to
figure out what happened or you just
want to see like the progress that is
going
once the pipeline runs end to end we
have an associated
uh object storage in that on that object
storage
all the dependencies have initially been
put in there to run each of the notebook
but then you start also seeing uh sort
of like the the results
so let me take a look here uh
the one that we were just looking at
uh i think it was this one
but we have a representation of
we have a a representation of that
notebook that that was run into html
which is very easy for
us to just take a look and see what's
going on
but you also have the the final ipy and
b that you can then reuse you can
download or share with others
other than that uh we have a couple of
other things on the line on the lyra let
me
uh just double check we have a few
minutes uh so
i mentioned to you guys we the pipeline
shows you basically multiple notebooks
tied together
if what you're having is just one
notebook
this case i just have a linear
regression notebook here
but maybe you're doing a model training
that can take
uh hours uh even more than just a couple
hours
you don't want to have your kind of like
notebook stuck there waiting for that to
happen
you can submit a notebook similarly you
will enter with
uh uh kind of like the runtime
configuration uh that you want
the image that you you want to run that
uh and when you execute we
we package this the same way we we add
dependencies
oh in this case there was a output
uh the environment variable that you can
feel if you needed
and uh we will then package it kind of
like a one node pipeline and submit the
same way to
keep flow pipelines uh and in this case
we
it's just a notebook there isn't much to
get it there you can see that it gets uh
quickly
submitted you then have the kind of like
a
link directly to there and also
information on where
all the data is going to be stored
i mentioned python script
so if for example when we were looking
to the
covid experiment we had
inside the notebooks we have some
utility pythons that you can start
adding to here
but sometimes you just have a script
that you want to run
so in this case i'm processing a data
set of that
kind of like talks about sacramento real
estate sales
and i want to uh i didn't identify the
the average price for a zip code uh
i can then select where i want to run
this these are
sort of like configurations uh kernel
configurations
and internally what it's actually going
to do is going to create a kernel
environment
and execute that by doing that we can
leverage hybrid runtime
and python 3 might be running locally
but it might actually be
running let's say on a cloud where you
have access to
things like gpu more data more cpu and
once i do a play here
basically you will see that it's very
transparent to where it's running uh
will do
all the execution uh all the things that
you need and will bring back
uh the kind of like output that you need
from that into here
and and that is very good you don't have
to go out to do
python scripts and things like that and
you get the results back here
and last uh not less but like let me
the last couple of things that i want to
bring up is
uh let me go back to kavid here this is
actually
a gate repository that i cloned you can
see things that got changed
you can select a
you can select here you can add things
to get staged or you can just see what
has been changed
uh very easily to identify changes here
in this case and
pretty much nothing other than metadata
files were changed
sorry metadata information were changed
so uh
it gives you a much better uh
visualization
and if you are just uh kind of like a
trying to to start something fresh
something clean
uh we can go create new notebooks as as
as we always do and we have introduced
this notion of like a code snippets
uh code snippets are reusable pieces of
code that it that usually you have to
repeat itself very much you don't have
to type that
very often so let's say i want to do
sort of like a some
plots with matplotlib i have some of the
initialization codes here that i use
very often
i can quickly just come create a new
notebook insert that
all like let me go and try to plot
actually a graph here and you can after
you did that you can start basically
executing those cells and voila we have
sort of like our graph here very easy
reused code
uh i have other information here i have
a scenario
here that is spark related it's actually
written in scala
so let me try to add here and see what's
going to happen so it's a little bit
intelligent it identifies that you are
using python
uh it then allows you to uh
give you a warning that is is really
what you want to do
uh let me see if i do other things like
i'm
creating a markdown and then i go to
code snippets
i can uh for example add to this here
it identifies that i'm actually adding
code to markdown it put kind of like a
look at the right
uh um kind of like uh wrapping around
that so it's sort of like a comment in
your
in your document uh so this is a very
high level
of like what we are doing with elira and
the overall idea here is we want to be
able to
simplify and get things better
particularly for
data scientists that are coming to
jupiter lab that are doing ai
and and might not have necessarily
all the cs background or or
needs to be involved on devops tasks
related to the model training
so uh this this is sort of it i mean a
lot of
resources here all that we are doing is
uh
open source you can go to github.com
lyra see all the code that we have there
is documentation there a couple of other
videos related to this so the
announcement goes a little bit more
deeper uh
on on demo of different functionalities
uh for those that are interested on more
on the analytics side of the
cove scenario i also have
a youtube video from fred rice
which goes into more of the details on
the analytics side
uh what kind of like uh uh issues
uh he found with the data how he solved
that
uh kind of like what what are some of
the uh actual models and
and things of pandas that he's
using for uh implementing that he's more
the data scientist and more kind of like
the platform guy
so uh feel free to reach out to me if
you have questions i think we
might still have a little bit of time or
not uh for
questions please thank you very much for
the time i think thank you very much for
for having me
yes thanks a lot for this talk luciano
thanks a lot
are there any questions
in the audience please use the chat or
the q a function
to post them
um yeah i i i have a question only if
you allow me
yes sure so um i noticed that that you
can use
a remote kernel execution
and you i think you mentioned uh docker
and how easy is for you to kind of
extend it
to to have kind of more resources to
take care of kind of a
big chunk of jobs or to
extend it or do you use something like
kubernetes or
some platform like that good good that
is probably another
talk about another talk to go into that
but
uh yes uh let me show just one slide
here and
i'm not sharing just a second
so internally uh when when we are doing
the the hybrid runtime
uh this is sort of like what's happening
and yes we have support for both
kind of like a uh platforms like
just running on a spark cluster or in a
kubernetes environment
and we we usually recommend those like
if you are doing analytics
uh kind of like using spark cluster is
better because you basically
playing with different data if you are
using things more like
ai uh in deep learning uh we recommend
kubernetes
uh mostly because you start in the
isolation
uh one one one notebook or one
job uh needs some sort of kind of like a
uh tensorflow background to to run where
others might be using just
kind of like a plan python or pytorch
and you name it
so what we do here is we have
integration with jupiter hub to spawn
your notebooks
but we also have the ability to like
bring your own notebook where you say
well i'm using my laptop and i'm just
going to connect remotely which is
mostly what i was doing today
in this case there is a piece that we
created a few years ago
and it's a project that jupiter called
jupiter enterprise gateway
that then enables you to start kind of
like either doing spike on kubernetes
or uh just playing vanilla uh kernels
and what it does is it creates a pod for
every
uh notebook or kernel that you start
startup
that allows you flexibility to choose
what image you want but also allows you
to
if you have something that needs gpus
and are running for four to three hours
once it's done
those resources are are returned back
where you might have other jobs that are
running uh
much longer and don't need those
resources so
you can just use more memory or more
more more cpu so yes
uh uh in inductor enterprise gateway is
what allows you to to give all that
flexibility
uh to to the data scientist and to the
environment
cool thank you very much the same seems
very interesting to kind of
reducing time for new people joining
your team and those sorts of
scenarios yeah it looks very interesting
yes i think
one of the the kind of like uh
why we started this was exactly that we
needed some kind of like a selfish
service analytics platform
so that people can come and just say i
need a an environment
but we also saw that the data scientist
kind of usage pattern
was more like yeah i come here i'm doing
some experiment i might go to
coffee come back three hours later and
all those resources
were always being used these allow
much more control and granularity of
like what resources you use for how long
thank you very much
yes thank you very much to uh
luciano and all the other speakers um
as i mentioned in the beginning uh there
were lots of people
involved in the background as well that
that helped to prepare the meetup and
helped with
the organization so thanks a lot for to
everyone
who was involved the help was very much
appreciated